Yeah, it's gonna be tough for him.
Well, they were trying to get him, um,
he was trying to get the
Conor McGregor fight.
That had been a tough fight for him.
It would've been a tough fight for him.
But at 155 pounds is not a bad
fight for him. No, not really.
But I mean,
the problem is stylistically he just does,
he doesn't move his head enough.
Yeah. You know, and Nate, I mean,
Nate doesn't either, but Nate took a lot
of shots, you know, to the hit. So I mean,
it's kind of a bad, I don't
know. Yeah. But Nate, Nate is a,
Nate is a very good boxer.
Yeah. Make a box. Nate Diaz is,
it frustrates the shit out of me
that he's not fighting. Why is that?
Because I like to see him.
I want to see him get in there.
I want to see him make
money while he can too.
I mean you're only going to be able
to live this lifestyle for, I mean,
I know he made a couple of million
dollars off of the Conor fight,
but he hasn't fought in two years more
than handling and else like put the dust
employee a fight that was going to happen,
but then Poria got injured,
he's got some hip issue and then he
pulled out of that fight. I just,
I was looking forward to that
fight. I want to, I want to
see him back in it. Yeah.
But I mean I would've loved to seen that
fight and then never supposed to find
Mazda doll. That's, that's not
going to happen. Oh, why? I Dunno.
That's the perfect fight.
Great fight the fight.
Where you going to got like the Hispanic
culture, the civil war and that's fine.
Yola going at it.
Yeah.
That would have been a great stylist
and like they would have talked trash to
each other.
It would have been crazy.
Whoever dropped the ball
on that needs to be fired.
I think nick just decided not fight. I
don't know. I do not know. I don't know.
I'm talking out of my ass.
I don't know the specifics,
but I was looking forward to it.
But then I saw an article that said Nate,
Nick Diaz confirms he's not going to
be fighting in the UFC to 35 I'm like,
what? What? Get in there. Oh come on man.
Last time we fought was Anderson Silva.
That's crazy. That is crazy. That's crazy.
But I don't know.
I mean I don't know Joe.
And this is something that we
kind of kind of stopped doing man.
Like maybe they ain't got it no more.
Well I don't know if it's,
he doesn't have it anymore because
we haven't seen him. Not Habit.
He fought well against Anderson Anderson's
185 pounder. I wouldn't lead down.
Yay. I mean, I mean,
I mean honestly if anybody could still
fight in her old age to weigh those Dib,
Diaz brothers fight their style will
allow them to fight longer cause they're
not like the best athletes. So they
were not I own skill and just endurance.
Endurance. Yeah. So they can fight longer.
So I'm assuming that they
still have something left in
the tank. I'm sure. I mean,
they're obviously not out of
shape. They're both things. Yeah,
they look like their fit.
I see them training,
I see pictures of them with Jujitsu gies
on and hitting the bag and shit. This,
you know,
who knows man.
I mean it's also like they want that
big payday, you know? Especially now,
and they should get that big payday.
But goddamn, if I was the UFC,
if I am fuck yeah,
I think those guys are superstars.
I think the UFC doesn't know.
I think one of the reasons why Nate
Diaz versus Conor McGregor was so big is
because people love Nate
Diaz to Yay Conor McGregor.
No doubt Conor Mcgregor,
no disrespect to Eddie Alvarez.
But when Conor McGregor
fight Eddie Alvarez,
the vast majority of the
eyes were on Conor McGregor.
When Conor McGregor fights Nate Diaz,
you,
you're looking at a lot of
people who love Nate Diaz. Yeah.
But how do you think that happened?
Like how do you think Nate
got that says that star power,
you think he legitimately doesn't give
a fuck? He smokes weed all the time.
People love it. They love the fact
that those guys are like that. No Man.
But what does that say about our
fan base and our society? Well,
I don't know. You know, what does the,
here's what's disappointing to me,
that for whatever reason,
mighty mouse never became
a giant superstar. Yeah.
That confused the shit out of me.
I'd watch that guy fight, you know,
when he took Ray Borg and suplex him and
caught him with an arm bar on the way
down and was like, what the fuck does
this guy have to do to become a superstar?
I mean,
his skill levels off the chart for sure.
It doesn't get hit for sure and put
it on, he's a dazzling fighter. Puts,
puts on show skill for skill.
There's nobody on the planet who can do
what he does now. He's the best ever.
He's the best physically ever.
Yeah.
When the only thing that keeps him from
being thought of as universally the
greatest of all time is Jon Jones and
Jon Jones been able to beat better guys.